let's talk about life under lockdown and
how the world is closing borders and
canceling events to stop the spread of
this car on a virus kovat 19 has
silenced entire cities
we've shut up shop - here's our whole
team still working but from home and I'm
in here I'm quarantined inside a hotel
in Doha after visiting family in Spain
but I know I'm not alone so many of you
have been told to self isolate - we've
seen this outbreak evolve from a few
cases of pneumonia in China and December
- a global pandemic that's testing
governments and people around the world
this is not a time for panic it's a time
to be fully prepared there's a lot to
make sense of so it's worth going over
the basics what do we know how do we
keep ourselves and others around us safe
and how long is this all going to last
there's a lot we still don't understand
about this coronavirus but we've been
speaking to experts all week who know
how abba demux work and they're saying
this isn't going to end anytime soon so
the mission right now is to manage the
spread scientists think that for every
person who has the virus between two and
three people can get infected so it
spreads exponentially you may have seen
this curve that the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention put out
it shows what the outbreak looks like if
we don't do anything so there's a surge
in the number of cases as the virus
spreads but the problem is there's a
limit to how much health systems can
cope with a spike like that that's why
experts say we need to flatten the curve
meaning we slow the spread and buy time
so hospitals don't collapse you might
have a million cases but instead of over
one month you're bringing it down over
four months or six months which is much
easier to manage from an infrastructure
and public health standpoint so how bad
could it get well one study in the UK
was pretty blunt if we do nothing and
let's remember that's not what's
happening here but if we do nothing the
report says more than half a million
people would die in Britain doing
something like restricting movement say
could cut that number in half but the
study says a full-on offensive meaning
tough measures for at least a year would
drop the death toll in the UK to less
than 20,000 and those numbers would be a
lot worse in countries with poor health
services or countries that just aren't
ready
in northern Italy some hospitals were
pushed to capacity it's a crowd at
frantic overwhelming place the system is
on the brink doctors have been forced to
choose who not to treat comparing
patients and choosing the patients who
have the best possibility to survive
it's always emotional and difficult to
decide
Italy's death toll is now well past
China's most of the dead are elderly the
army is had to transport hundreds of
bodies to be cremated no proper funerals
no time for goodbyes just a tribute in
the newspapers long obituaries section
idiot it's heartbreaking but we can take
some comfort in knowing how this virus
affects us most people show mild to
moderate symptoms from getting a cold to
having pneumonia that doesn't require
hospitalization we infected a lot of
people not even knowing and that's the
issue that if you're asymptomatic or you
just happy a mild symptoms still stay
home but many others are getting
severely even critically ill and that
includes younger people a u.s. study
found that nearly 40% of Americans who
had to be hospitalized were between 20
and 54 years old but even those who get
to stay at home don't have it easy I
started having a headache on Tuesday and
then I started with a cough on Friday it
was a feeling of drowsiness and trying
to like fall back
I just wanted to fall asleep I didn't
realize what it actually was until my
parents came back positive with the
tests then there are the people who are
most at risk of dying from this virus
w-h-o says that's anyone over 60 and
people with underlying conditions or
disorders and we all know people who
have them our friend with asthma a
relative who's going through
chemotherapy our neighbor who's pregnant
my little one especially if he were to
get the virus I don't know what would
happen because he's got asthma and it
would it would attack his his
respiratory system so how do we protect
ourselves let me just set something up
the whu-oh and the CDC say there have
been a few cases of the virus being
passed on by someone with no symptoms
but the risk is very low
the main way you get covered 19:00 is
from someone who is visibly sick you can
catch it from someone coughing sneezing
or even speaking a little too close to
you but what if those droplets linger a
recent study suggests the
I can survive in the air for up to three
hours now see those droplets land
somewhere well studies show the virus
can survive there too on cardboard it
can live up to 24 hours 3 days on
plastic two days on stainless steel
that's why the experts say wipe things
down even regular soap kills the virus
wash our hands avoid touching our face
and stay at least a metre away from
people if you're out and about finally
we just kind of have to put our old
lives on hold
shops and businesses have closed people
are losing their jobs countries aren't
letting people in it's clear now that
this is going to devastate economies in
Europe and America more than half a
billion children aren't in school even
praying isn't what it used to be
birthday parties weddings they may not
happen this year not to mention all
these events that so many people were
looking forward to concerts sports film
festivals they're all canceled so the
question is how long is this all going
to last that depends on where you live
how many cases there are and how strict
the lockdown is but this isn't
short-term it's safe to say that we're
gonna be in this for at least several
more months that things are still
continuing to ramp up we don't even have
a real sense of how many cases we have
I'll speak for the United States because
testing has been severely lagging and
that's a problem because the w-h-o says
the focus has to be on testing we cannot
stop this pandemic if we don't know who
is infected we have a simple message for
all countries test test test
the lock downs help we have more time to
find out who actually has the virus and
trace where it came from now the tests
can vary it could involve taking a
sample from deep inside your nose or a
throat but that takes supplies and
specialists many countries have not been
systemically testing all suspect cases
it's one of the reasons why we're behind
in this epidemic at the same time
there's this hope for a vaccine or that
the virus might ease up in summer the
bad news is yes companies aren't working
on a vaccine but it could take years to
roll it out to everyone that's for the
warmer weather slowing this down
I just don't know things that kill
viruses are sunlight and drying out but
I want to be clear that we do not know
and have no data to support the idea
that this virus will go away as the
seasons change and things warm up so the
advice is to write out the lockdowns as
best we can
reaching out to people and making one
another laughs counts for a lot too
here's some good news
China and South Korea which saw the
earliest peaks took aggressive action
and saw the number of cases dropped
dramatically by March people have
started going back to work
businesses are slowly opening back up
but that doesn't mean we can relax there
is a real risk that is some of the
restrictions on society loosen and relax
we may see a resurgence of cases and
that's because it is so difficult to
determine how many people are still
getting exposed and infected that may
not be reporting because they have mild
or asymptomatic cases in short we take
this seriously without fear we listen to
the experts we stay informed we look out
for each other and we carry on
we don't know when we'll be back on the
start here to set but not to worry we're
still going to be bringing you more
episodes anyway we can in the meantime
my website aljazeera.com has all the
latest on the corona virus pandemic I'll
see you next week